Aquí tenemos dos piezas importantes
para resolver nuestro problema.
Primero nos dicen que 11 es igual a 8,
más la función inversa de "x" -3
y por otra parte tengo que
"f" de 3 es igual a 10.
Lo que quiero que hagas justo ahorita, es que pauses
el vídeo e intentes encontrar el valor de "x".
Y bueno, tal vez en un principio
esto suene bastante llamativo,
y tener una función inversa por aquí,
sin embargo lo primero que yo haría es intentar simplificar lo más que se pueda esta información.
Así que en esta ecuación que tengo aquí,
donde está involucrada la función inversa,
lo que se me ocurre primero, es restar 8 de ambos lados, de esta igualdad.
De tal manera que aquí voy a restar 8,
y de este lado también voy a restar 8,
para que solamente quede de un lado
la función inversa,
y entonces, ¿qué me va a quedar?
Bueno, pues de este lado me queda,
11 menos 8 lo cual es 3,
ok, y del otro lado me va a quedar que estos dos se van y solamente me queda la función inversa de "x" menos 3
así que le voy a apuntar aquí,
la función inversa de "x" menos 3.
¡De lujo!
y es más, lo puedo escribir también por aquí,
"f" a la -1 de "x" menos 3...
de "x" menos 3...
esto es exactamente igual que 3,
porque al final, aquí tenemos dos piezas,
muy importantes de información,
que nos van a ayudar a resolver el problema,
después de que simplificamos justo por aquí
y es que por aquí hay algo bastante interesante,
fíjate,
en un principio dice "f" de 3,
esto es igual las 10,
y por otra parte me dice que,
la función inversa de "x" menos 3
esto es lo mismo que 3.
Aquí hay algo bastante interesante
y es que basta recordar que significa
tomarnos la función inversa.
Si por ejemplo, aquí tuviera...
vamos a dibujar por acá...
aquí tengo el dominio de esta función...
el dominio de esta función...
y por acá,
por acá imagínate que tengo
el codominio de esta función,
y lo voy a poner aquí...
el codominio...
codominio...
¡Ok!
y lo que nosotros sabemos es que,
la función mapea el 3 al 10,
si nosotros tenemos por aquí al 3...
al 3 lo mapea al valor de 10,
esto en la función.
Eso quiere decir que entonces la función inversa
mapea del -10 al 3.
Esto en la función inversa,
la función inversa mapea al 10 al valor de 3,
por lo tanto "f" inversa del 10
es lo mismo que 3,
y déjame apuntarlo aquí,
"f"
inversa, ¿ok?
de 10,
esto es exactamente igual que 3.
Por lo tanto esta igualdad, no está diciendo lo mismo, que esta igualdad,
o dicho de otra manera,
"x" menos 3...
"x" menos 3,
tiene que ser lo mismo que 10,
"x" menos 3, tiene que ser lo mismo que 10
y si ahora sumamos 3 de ambos lados,
voy a obtener que "x" es lo mismo que 13
y ya está aquí,
tenemos por fin el valor de "x".